mdc-3 you are the winner of
world of dan
[Applause]
congratulations take me back to that
moment
when you're on stage and they announce
you the chance of season four world of
dance
your reaction is dream state pure joy
were you shocked
because we had no idea like what the
judges
were gonna like and who they were gonna
pick and it was just a coin talks like
who was gonna win it was breathtaking at
moments
and i could not take my eyes off of you
guys obviously
you guys are no stranger to the
competition world you've been competing
for years together but what does it mean
to be named the world's
best according to jlo derekov
and nia what does that mean it just
feels like
unreal like that we even got the chance
to perform in front of them
like going into all the dance we were
like let's just try to make it past
jewels and win our division
and then we found out there were no
divisions we just kept going like round
by round oh we can maybe win this like
we really put the word you definitely
took it step by step
and it's insane to say that we won the
world's biggest dance competition
ever so yeah it's pretty cool well tell
me this because it really was a season
full of surprises i mean from the minute
you guys
stepped on to audition and the judges
were there unexpectedly
all the way to the finale where there
was no audience i mean
what was it like having to do that last
performance especially when you're so
used to
giving your energy and feeding off the
energy of people in a crowd what was
like having to perform with no audience
[Music]
we like thrive with an audience because
that's like what we're known
to like do like we love an audience so
when we were told that we wouldn't have
one
for a finale dance which takes a lot out
of us that was definitely one of our
like hardest dances
we were really nervous but i was like
also kind of relieved because going on
the semi-finals with that audience
around us was like
i was terrified yeah
it was definitely a bummer to not have
the energy of an audience around us
but it just allowed us to like zone in
on each other
even more and focus on what we needed to
get done
yeah i think what really helped us was
that our families were watching so that
really
gave us some energy too you know we
could obviously hear the judges because
they have a microphone on reacting
throughout your dance
[Music]
could you hear other people like maybe
your family backstage or even like
yeah you could hear them on stage yeah
oh i'm sure that helped right a little
bit i like
didn't really i kind of toned out
because you had your mind
i did not really hear anything maybe
they did yeah but
i just kept thinking how nerve-wracking
that is actually because it's just so
silent
right i think your music starts but you
guys have clearly turned it out and it
was amazing
and it's the tricks it's the amazing
things that you can do
but honestly it's the quality of your
that gave me dance thank you yeah what
did it feel like to hear
jlo praise your dancing and say she that
you gave her gooses
you know that the magic word gooses what
did that feel like it was an
honor to hear her say that for sure
because we heard her say it very minimal
times on the show and we are definitely
one of her favorite acts she said that
she's ever seen and
she loved every performance that we had
to offer which was super cool
the feedback we like received from the
judges on every single routine was like
just we're so excited about it because i
think it showed our consistency
throughout the show and that's something
we're really proud of yeah like the
judges feedback
means so much to us because like they're
one of our all of our biggest
inspirations right now so that just
meant so much to us
so was there added pressure then for
this last i mean obviously it's the
last performance right so there's
already so much pressure but knowing
that
you got a chance to actually perform it
in front of the judges who mentored you
gave you some advice like did that add
any more pressure to you
it wasn't really like that added
pressure for like every round
but the most like pressure we had was
how
we were supposed to perform on saturday
and it got switched to friday like a day
early because of porn team yeah
that was definitely a really big
struggle but push through
i wanted to talk about your semi-finals
performance because you guys
you hot you had me sobbing on my couch i
was like
what oh why am i crying like i cried
j.lo obviously was overcome with emotion
um i mean like annie earned you guys the
highest score
of that round
[Music]
at what point did you guys feel like oh
my gosh you know what we have a real
chance of winning this thing
definitely semi-finals after semi-finals
we
really thought that we had a good chance
at winning and so
we put everything we had into our final
routine
and just gave it our all and rehearsed a
ton
yeah we got like the highest score out
of both semis too which is
absolutely incredible and those are good
so much confidence going into the fight
absolutely
um you know obviously maddie that
performance particular was a tribute to
your mom who battled cancer
uh what would you say for all of you
guys what was the toughest performance
to get through
i would say either finals or semis for
me because
all those lips were like really damaging
on my body
and it just really hurt and it was
filmed
within like like a shorter time than the
other two we had this breaks
so the two like going back to back were
really hard
i would say the duels round was my
hardest because it was so jam-packed for
me i was like lifting
the tricks and do a dance break together
but how good did it feel when derek huff
recognized that though
right he knew he's like you're putting
it in work man he's like one of my
biggest inspirations too and like
hearing that with him just
means the world you know yeah for sure i
would say
semi-finals was definitely the most
emotional
emotionally draining for me because i
went through a lot of pouring out all my
emotions through the dance and
the whole interview process and it was
one of the first times like i talked
about my mom's cancer journey
out loud so that was really tough on me
uh and i love what the judges said and
they said this to you guys throughout
the competition that you guys are
um athletes but your true storytellers
too and it really showed especially with
that semi-finals performance
um but when you look back at the entire
competition what moment
will you guys remember the most
definitely winning
it was like moving on to every round it
was really memorable for us
but i mean winning was obviously the
biggest moment
even after duels and 70s we felt really
great
yeah obviously winning is such a huge
deal your families were there how did
you guys celebrate
it was a while ago right
we went to dinner
[Music]
kids you're crazy kids it was really
late
and we're all pretty tired yeah we
passed out
i believe that i believe that um so
obviously the million dollar question is
how do you
plan to spend the million dollar prize
well i
definitely gonna go on a shopping spree
yes you did a lot of work
you learned it i want to get an
apartment in la
because i just graduated and want to
dance professionally now
and then save the rest probably
definitely going on a shopping spree
getting some new clothes and new shoes
and
saving for an apartment next year there
you go uh i'm turning 16 in november
so i want to get a car and maybe throw a
sweet 16
and then save a lot of a lot of it
i love it i mean what's next you guys
are going to be hitting up j.lo and neo
to be in their next music videos like
what you gotta do to get on their next
project
what would be the goals yes that's the
goal for sure
a lot of jobs planned out for us and we
plan to do more events and music videos
yeah we're gonna still stay together
you are you're gonna are you guys gonna
still compete together as well yeah of
course
oh good the world needs to see you guys
dance some more
you guys are so talented and i couldn't
be uh more thrilled for you so
congratulations
thank you so much